I'm doing all right you know I had sex
with my wife today or she calls it micro
dosing and uh
we got married I remember we got engaged
she was like you got a post about it you
gotta post about the engagement I was
like why she's like it's like this is
between us who cares about social media
she's like I want people to know like
all right well I'll wait a post by that
threesome we had
she's like why the hell would I do that
I'm like I want people to know
she's like what are you kidding this is
a bond between two people I'm like this
is better it's a bomb between three
she's like what I've been dreaming about
this since I was a little kid I was like
yeah a lot of young girls dream about a
wedding a lot of young boys dream about
a threesome and the dream is very
similar right who we gonna invite where
are we going to do it we got to get a
photographer
[Applause]